[Music]
we were so close
but I'll keep trying
I will find a cure I will
I love you son
where are you going I need to find Otto
yes the anti zero maybe you can't
maybe spider-man needs help from his
friend Peter Peter help build those arms
remember if anyone can find a weakness
it's him
[Music]
go get him tiger
all right no no that's not it
maybe it's this one no I'm not an expert
or anything but I think it's in the way
that you asked her hey I'm getting too
nervous
hey all right so where do you want this
uh writer is fine hey so Pete yeah I
kind of got to talk to you about
something I can't tell my mom about
what's up well um
weird things have been going on like
physically oh oh well you know you're at
that age where where your your body
starts to change and so you may be
noticing some areas though for example
not that things he's better that I just
um
I show you sure no no no no [ __ ] it's
pretty weird right
[Music]
not everybody is Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to check out
spider-man ps4 it seems like the whole
world has been playing it this weekend
but big things happen in this
post-credit scene some people were a
little confused about what's going on
here so I'll explain because it involves
a couple big changes to the comic book
backstory but it answers a couple big
questions about big spider-man villains
that we didn't know whether or not we're
going to be in the game which now is of
course confirmed which is pretty cool
I'm still doing a round to that
spider-man ps4 giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video so
chronologically the first actual
post-credits scene is that Miles Morales
won but the venom one is a little bit
bigger because it involves some big
story twists so that's why I put it at
the beginning of this video so what's
going on here is is that Harry Osborn in
the game is spider-man's friend
historically but he's not really in the
game you just hear a bunch of voicemails
from him left for Peter in the labs that
you go into so you're like well where is
he all the people keep referring to him
being on a European vacation because he
has a degenerative disease and he's
looking for treatment overseas so this
is where we get into the Norman Osborn
Oscorp up at all what happens is is
Norman Osborn started Oscorp
with Doctor Octopus within the game
Norman Osborn wanted to start doing
really crazy genetic testing in all
kinds of experimentation the Doctor
Octopus wasn't really cool with at the
time remember he started out as a good
character that slowly became evil so
Otto Octavius leaves Oscorp in its early
days goes out on his own and Norman
Osborn just continues with all of his
research experiments eventually he
develops what he thinks is going to be a
cure for Harry's degenerative condition
that becomes Devil's breath which is
this poisonous serum that kills anybody
it's a big part of the plot and Martin
Lee who's mr. negative who you seen in
all the trailers was one of the earliest
test subjects the serum gave him his
powers he accidentally killed his
parents so he has a vendetta against
Norman Osborn within the context of the
game Norman Osborn is the mayor so what
happens is is he has all these labs set
up around the city in conjunction with
kingpin so you have all these criminals
working together on the DL to try and
develop this serum mr. negative wants to
release it on the public as
revenge against Norman Osborn Mary Jane
is the person that eventually outs
Norman Osborn so after he finally finds
a cure so to speak for Harry he resigns
as mayor and just goes about his
business then you see him in this post
credits scene we'll keep trying but then
you see him with the symbiote so Harry
Osborn is going to be the venom of
spider-man ps4 eventually in an upcoming
DLC pack everybody was wondering if they
were gonna do Eddie Brock because we
have the venom movie coming up and of
course the game is gonna try and do
movie tie-ins like they've already done
the infinity war tie-in in the
homecoming tie-in with the different
stark tech suits for those of you asking
about Green Goblin you also find
prototype goblin grenades in Oscorp
slabs so that just implies that Norman
Osborn will eventually become the Green
Goblin of the game if he isn't already
and Harry Osborn will be venom but it's
all through Mary Jane's storyline so the
other post credits scene the Miles
Morales one is also a bit of a Mary Jane
storyline so when she's investigating
Oscorp getting all this evidence about
the Devil's breath serum that they're
creating one of the spiders spider
number 42 hitches a ride on her and as
you saw during that clip eventually
makes its way down to Miles Morales
bites him in the thing is is that spider
42 is the spider that bit him in the
comics so the cool thing about that is
that Miles Morales will be playable in
upcoming DLC as ultimate spider-man
obviously he'll probably eventually make
his costume it'll probably be a big part
of the story down the road because
earlier in the game you teach him to
fight he really is a big part of the
game so I think they're just creating
room for him to be a much bigger part
later on what they'll probably do with
the venom stuff is they'll talk more
about that DLC after the venom movie
comes out there is a reference to Peter
Parker symbiote suit earlier in the game
when URI asked him if he has a black
suit to wear to a ball he just kind of
chuckles and it's a little awkward and
you brush it off but it's just meant to
be an easter egg for Peter when he had
the symbiote but obviously that's
different during the events of this game
meaning that after Harry fully manifests
as venom and you start fighting him
during the game eventually there will be
DLC that will allow you to obtain
Peter's symbiote costume so that you'll
be able to wear
during the game yourself so if you're
wondering why there's 27 different
versions of the costume at the beginning
of the game that you can obtain but no
symbiote suit
that's probably why and just remember
that they'll be way more DLC there's
already three packs that they've
announced so there'll be more suits that
will be unveiled because of all the
story that happens during those I like
black cat is the next big DLC that
they're doing I put that at the
beginning of my review video a little
while ago so I'll link that at the end
of this if you haven't played the game
yet be sure to check it out it's
fantastic
all these post-credit scenes imply
that's gonna be doing really cool stuff
down the road so we'll see what they
continue to unveil because we don't know
a whole lot about the second or the
third DLC packs yet but all three of
them are coming before the end of the
year so it's not like you're gonna have
to wait for forever to get all that
stuff there's a couple more videos that
I'm working on so I'll try to get that
stuff out as fast as possible I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
but click here to watch a scene with
Nick Fury from spider-man far from home
and click here for my spider-man ps4
review video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]